being overly confident with with my  fitness and thinking like well i can do  that like this and it's you know crazy  [ __ ] like racing horses you know however  fast across an open plane and and i got  away with all of it until one day i  didn't one day i took a really bad ball  and fractured my um my l3 and  subsequently herniated three discs and  let me tell you  i never understood the meaning of pain  until that happened what happened you  know when you get caught up in like the  instagram [ __ ] of like oh you're doing  something  for shits and giggles like it serves no  purpose i made a mistake slipped and  fell  and all those years of like being so  careful and eating all the right foods  and you know building my core strength  and balancing my biomechanics  like it is second another one divorcing  your body bye  bye  you can come back to me in like two  months oh three months couldn't walk  couldn't stand had to crawl on the floor